hold on one more time can you just say
that I just didn't hear you 95 percent
of our leads come from Tick Tock and
Instagram hold on I didn't hear you one
more time 95 percent of our leads come
from Tick Tock Instagram YouTube search
LinkedIn and all the social media
platforms
and he's only been at it for two years
he doesn't even know what he's doing yet
we must really understand the art part
of underpriced attention for our
businesses the single thing that can
change the majority of businesses in
this room is an obnoxious commitment to
organic social media creative as an
opportunity to take advantage of the
tick tock of vacation of social media
that will be the next half decade your
product or you however you want to play
it both preferably that you can post
your first post on a YouTube shorts or a
tick tock and if you know what you're
doing a lot of good things can happen
for your business is exciting